Tersity empowers economical expression. And if you have economical expression, it allows you to be simpler longer for more complexity. We've talked about before how algorithms in C++ are so important. There's a lot of people that say, why do I have to go learn these algorithms? A for loop is good enough. And we've advocated on this podcast that algorithms elevate your vocabulary. If algorithms are your vocabulary, notation is the analog of that for thought. Cheers.
简洁赋予了表达的经济性。如果你拥有经济的表达方式，它就能让你在更长的时间里保持简单，从而实现更高的复杂度。我们之前讨论过 C++ 中的算法有多么重要。很多人会问，我为什么要学习这些算法？一个 for 循环不就够了吗？我们在本播客中一直主张，算法能提升你的词汇量。如果说算法是你的词汇，那么符号系统就是思想的类比。干杯。
Cheers. That was amazing. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 197, recorded on August 21st, 2024. My name is Connor, and today I interview Aaron Hsu on-site at the Eagle Pub in the University of Cambridge. In today's episode, we chat about the importance of algorithms and tersity in programming languages. Cheers. Cheers. All right. All right.
干杯。太棒了。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 197 期，录制于 2024 年 8 月 21 日。我是 Connor，今天我在剑桥大学的 Eagle 酒馆采访 Aaron Hsu。在今天的节目中，我们聊聊编程语言中算法和简洁性的重要性。干杯。干杯。好了。好了。
All right. Get into the serious stuff. We're back, folks. It's episode, I didn't even mention what episode it was last time. It's episode, I think, 197 now. We just got done recording 196. We're back with Aaron Hsu, famous for his GPU code defunds compiler. We just finished talking about algorithms.
好了。进入正题。伙计们，我们回来了。这是第……我上次甚至没提是哪一期。我想现在是第 197 期了。我们刚录完 196 期。我们又请回了以 GPU 代码编译器而闻名的 Aaron Hsu。我们刚刚讨论完算法。
We might have to make it a recurring thing every few months. We'll bring you back to talk about algorithm implementations on the CPU versus the GPU. And you can choose the one in advance that you want to talk about because it's – I think it is interesting to talk about the tradeoffs. And that's an interesting thing about the dialog implementations. A lot of time they have these kind of upfront heuristic things. They'll do like a single pass reduction to collect some kind of like Boolean predicate data. And then from there they'll dispatch to one of two or three algorithms.
我们可能得把它变成每几个月一次的常态。我们会请你回来讨论 CPU 与 GPU 上的算法实现。你可以提前选择你想讨论的内容，因为我认为讨论其中的权衡是非常有趣的。这是对话式实现的一个有趣之处。很多时候，它们会有一些预先的启发式处理。它们会进行类似单次扫描的归约，以收集某种布尔谓词数据。然后从那里开始，它们会分发给两到三种算法中的一种。
Or 15. Or 15. Well, we're going to have to talk about those. And so it's like when you talk, like I know that I've talked to both Adam and Marshall, who both, I mean, Adam still is working in Dialog and Marshall used to, about what is the algorithm implementation. They're like, well, it depends on your data. Anyways, a topic for another day.
或者 15 种。或者 15 种。好吧，我们得聊聊那些。所以当你谈论时，我知道我和 Adam 以及 Marshall 都聊过，我的意思是，Adam 还在 Dialog 工作，而 Marshall 以前在那里工作，关于算法实现是什么。他们说，嗯，这取决于你的数据。总之，这是改天的话题。
The question that we're going to talk about now, as previewed in 196, episode 196, we'll link it in the show notes. Aaron recently talked at LambdaConf. I know you've given several talks in years past. And I can't actually remember which talk it was. I'll link it in the show notes. Aaron recently talked at LambdaConf. I know you've given several talks in years past. And I can't actually remember which talk it was. I'll link both of them. But there was a key moment where you kind of made an offhand comment. And it was that tersity is fundamental.
我们现在要讨论的问题，正如在 196 期节目中所预告的那样，我们会在节目说明中附上链接。Aaron 最近在 LambdaConf 上做了演讲。我知道你过去几年做过几次演讲。我其实记不清是哪一次了。我会把它们都附在节目说明里。但有一个关键时刻，你随口提了一句。那就是简洁性是根本。
It underpins the power of APL. And without the tersity of APL, you don't have APL. Yep. And this is something that I believe inside, deep in my core. But arguing that just because something's terse, it makes it powerful is something that I don't know how to pitch that argument. Whether it's APL or just having some language that's on the command line, whether it's you know, sed, awk, there's a lot of other languages jq for json that aren't
它是 APL 力量的基石。没有 APL 的简洁性，就没有 APL。是的。这是我内心深处坚信的东西。但是，仅仅因为某样东西简洁就说它强大，我不知道该如何推销这个观点。无论是 APL 还是命令行上的某种语言，无论是 sed、awk，还有很多其他像 jq 这样的 JSON 语言，它们不
necessarily APL, but there's a power to, yeah, grep there's a power, even regex, to these languages that are the opposite of verbose and you made this comment and you are much more articulate when it comes to advocating for the things that you believe in.
一定是 APL，但这些语言——是的，grep，甚至正则表达式——有一种力量，它们与冗长截然相反。你发表了这个评论，而且你在倡导你所信仰的事物时表达得要清晰得多。
So this is my question, is why? And why should people care about and think about the verbosity of their code and whether they can make it terser to make it more powerful? All right, here we go. Yeah, we got to settle in for something like this because this is not an easy question to strongly support because there's so much institutional momentum around the concept of quote-unquote readable code as juxtaposed against tersity and this idea of abstraction and additive code and a lot of assumptions that people make assuming certain things about just the reality of software engineering that would force you into the conclusion that tersity is a dangerous tool right and the closest we get in most arguments is that, well, you would like your code to be smaller,
所以我的问题是，为什么？为什么人们应该关心并思考代码的冗长程度，以及他们是否可以通过使其更简洁来使其更强大？好了，我们开始吧。是的，我们得静下心来讨论这类问题，因为这并不是一个容易有力支持的问题，因为围绕“可读代码”这一概念存在巨大的体制惯性，它与简洁性相对立，还有关于抽象和累加代码的想法，以及人们在假设软件工程现实时所做出的许多假设，这些假设会迫使你得出简洁性是一种危险工具的结论，对吧？我们在大多数争论中能达到的最接近的共识是，好吧，你希望你的代码更小，
up to the point where you start not violating certain types of style rules that are usually pretty verbose. So I think the first thing we need to understand is why is it so hard for people to intuitively embrace the idea of tarsity, right? And in this respect, we have to look at the history of the wisdom of what good code should look like, right? And so in the past, you have the 60s, the 70s, the Wild West of programming. People don't really care too much
直到你开始违反某些通常非常冗长的风格规则。所以我认为我们首先需要理解的是，为什么人们直觉上很难接受简洁性的概念，对吧？在这方面，我们必须回顾关于好代码应该是什么样子的智慧历史，对吧？在过去，你有 60 年代、70 年代，那是编程的蛮荒西部。人们并不太关心
about how your code looks. What they care about is just solving some stinking problems right like just get anything to work i don't care if you have to self-rewrite your own memory to fit it on the punch card make the thing work right and the and in those spaces cleverness ruled the day right because you had to be really clever figuring out exactly what it is you're doing on these very esoteric architectures, each of which is bespoke. You're working down at the machine level, even if you're at a high-level language, right? But something happens, right? Something shifts.
你的代码看起来怎么样。他们关心的是解决一些该死的问题，对吧？比如，只要能让东西跑起来就行，我不在乎你是否必须重写自己的内存来把它塞进打孔卡里，让它工作就行，对吧？在那些空间里，聪明才智占据了主导地位，对吧？因为你必须非常聪明地弄清楚你在这些非常深奥的架构上到底在做什么，每一个架构都是定制的。即使你使用的是高级语言，你也是在机器层面工作，对吧？但发生了一些事情，对吧？发生了一些转变。
And we begin to scale our programs up. And we don't have tools to scale software up. We don't know the tools. We don't have a theory for how to scale software up. We don't know the tools. We don't have a theory for how to scale software. And this spawns off the modern software engineering craze, where people are trying to figure out how do we make bigger and bigger pieces of software? How do we make them run? How do we make them reliable? How do we stop having things blow up in our faces, sometimes literally, right? And this whole wave, I would say, really strongly gets a lot of its push initially from what we call imperative programming today, but which at the time was called structured programming. So we get the idea that you can use structured programming to get a handle on complexity.
我们开始扩展我们的程序。但我们没有扩展软件的工具。我们不知道这些工具。我们没有关于如何扩展软件的理论。我们不知道这些工具。我们没有关于如何扩展软件的理论。这催生了现代软件工程热潮，人们试图弄清楚我们如何制造越来越大的软件？我们如何让它们运行？我们如何让它们可靠？我们如何防止事情在我们脸上爆炸，有时甚至是字面意义上的爆炸，对吧？我认为，整个浪潮在很大程度上最初受到我们今天所说的命令式编程的推动，但在当时被称为结构化编程。所以我们得到了一个想法，即你可以使用结构化编程来控制复杂性。
And from the very beginning, people recognized that management of complexity was the biggest challenge in software. That people have understood. And everybody since then has understood things like incremental development, the need for breaking things down into small pieces, the need to somehow absorb this information in a way that's accessible to the human mind, right? To solve these problems. But structured programming programming imperative programming comes with it the dykstra school of thought which is this idea of formal methods around programming the idea that you can be very rigorous about how you think about the structure of your programs and sort of prove important things you get tony hoare who develops the hoare around state and managing memory and things like that. And this spawns a whole base of early axiomatic systems on how to reason about programs.
从一开始，人们就认识到复杂性管理是软件中最大的挑战。这一点人们已经理解了。从那时起，每个人都理解了诸如增量开发、将事物分解成小块的必要性、以人类思维可访问的方式吸收这些信息的需求，对吧？来解决这些问题。但结构化编程、命令式编程随之而来的是 Dijkstra 的思想流派，即围绕编程的形式化方法的思想，即你可以对如何思考程序的结构非常严谨，并证明一些重要的事情。你有了 Tony Hoare，他开发了关于状态和管理内存的 Hoare 逻辑等等。这催生了关于如何推理程序的早期公理系统的基础。
And they all are based on structured programming, right? So the entire ethos of how to make reliable code stems from the structured programming models, which then turn into object-oriented models. All of this that you're saying, it doesn't necessitate verbosity. It doesn't? Well, it kind of does, but not for the reason you might think, right? The verbosity comes from the core abstractions
它们都基于结构化编程，对吧？因此，如何编写可靠代码的整个精神源于结构化编程模型，然后演变成面向对象的模型。你说的这一切，并不必然导致冗长。不是吗？嗯，某种程度上是这样，但不是你可能认为的原因，对吧？冗长来自于核心抽象
that became foundational at that time, right? So the core abstractions at that time were what you would see in C. What eventually became C, these are the core structured programming foundations that you get in your early Fortran, ALGOL, C, COBOL-type programs. You get these if-then-else clauses, these switch statements, these loops, the while loop, the for loop. And there were arguments about which ones were better, but it all put your data at a certain level of abstraction. And it was really the scalar abstraction level, right?
在那个时代成为了基础，对吧？所以那个时代的核心抽象就是你在 C 语言中看到的。最终演变成 C 语言的，这些就是你在早期 Fortran、ALGOL、C、COBOL 类程序中得到的核心结构化编程基础。你得到了这些 if-then-else 子句、这些 switch 语句、这些循环、while 循环、for 循环。关于哪些更好有一些争论，但它们都把你的数据放在了某种抽象层面上。那确实是标量抽象层面，对吧？
And all of this was very operational and organized around the machines at the time, which had very limited register sets on scalar operations. And in the 80s, there was a little bit of a parallel computation wave. People were trying to come up with massively parallel systems. And that, ironically, was the time at which APL also had a lot of uptake and was one of the dominant languages. He said APL. For a second, I thought he said JPL.
所有这些都非常具有操作性，并且围绕着当时的机器组织，这些机器在标量操作上只有非常有限的寄存器集。在 80 年代，有一点并行计算浪潮。人们试图提出大规模并行系统。讽刺的是，那也是 APL 也有很多采用并成为主流语言之一的时期。他说 APL。有一秒钟我以为他说的是 JPL。
And I was like, that's NASA. JPL actually is one of the still harbingers of the grand software engineering formalism tradition. But if you look at all of that stuff, you get to this point of we need to be able to reason about this code in a certain way. And so there's this institution of software engineering that latches on to structured programming and object-oriented programming around all of this. And so there's this core foundational abstraction that's chosen. latches onto structured programming and object-oriented programming around all of this. And so there's this core foundational abstraction that's chosen. And it's chosen, and if you look at the arguments between that and APL at the time,
我想那是 NASA。JPL 实际上仍然是宏大的软件工程形式主义传统的先驱之一。但如果你看看所有这些东西，你就会达到我们需要能够以某种方式推理这些代码的地步。因此，软件工程机构围绕所有这些东西坚持结构化编程和面向对象编程。所以选择了一个核心基础抽象。坚持结构化编程和面向对象编程。所以选择了一个核心基础抽象。它是被选择的，如果你看看当时它与 APL 之间的争论，
there's this, a lesson begins to emerge that, well, this other type of code is more readable, right? And people start saying, well, APL is a write-only language. So terse languages, the representatives of terse languages, begin to get this reputation of spaghetti code. And spaghetti code is one of these things that everybody's terrified of at the time. And nobody really has theory to prove any of this. It's just who chooses what to do. And there's this giant success that people are seeing with software engineering. And during the 90s, object-oriented programming was supposed to save the world in some sense, right? And you get Java, you get these
开始出现一个教训，即，嗯，这种其他类型的代码更具可读性，对吧？人们开始说，嗯，APL 是一种只写语言。因此，简洁语言，简洁语言的代表，开始获得意大利面条式代码的声誉。而意大利面条式代码是当时每个人都害怕的事情之一。而且没有人真正有理论来证明这一切。这只是谁选择做什么的问题。人们在软件工程中看到了巨大的成功。在 90 年代，面向对象编程在某种意义上被认为可以拯救世界，对吧？你有了 Java，你有了所有这些支持这种抽象模型的
garbage collectors, you get all these systems that support this abstraction model. And all of that begins to then develop into what does good code look like? And the vast majority of people arguing about what good code looks like are already steeped in this core foundational abstraction that they built up. And in that foundation, what you're dealing with is these modules that quickly exceed the human capacity for reasoning around them, right? So people start to then say, oh, well, these formal methods can't be handled by human minds at scale. This is one of the classic problems that people have. So then you begin to get this principle, this proverb in your head, that we will never be able to understand the full system.
垃圾回收器，你有了所有这些系统。所有这些开始发展成好代码是什么样子的？绝大多数争论好代码是什么样子的人都已经沉浸在他们建立的这个核心基础抽象中。在那个基础上，你处理的是那些很快超过人类推理能力的模块，对吧？所以人们开始说，哦，好吧，这些形式化方法在规模上无法被人类思维处理。这是人们面临的经典问题之一。所以你开始在脑海中形成这个原则，这个谚语，即我们永远无法理解整个系统。
And since we can never understand the full system, the key is to make sure that we break it apart in such a way that we never have to think about the whole system, right? Think small, think modular. And then we start thinking about as we grow software teams, we still have this sort of Taylor-esque attitude towards software management, which is very hierarchical, very control-oriented, very much write this specification and then have programmers implement it. Well, if you're going to write a specification and have programmers
既然我们永远无法理解整个系统，关键是要确保我们以一种永远不必考虑整个系统的方式将其拆解，对吧？小处着眼，模块化思考。然后我们开始思考，随着我们扩大软件团队，我们仍然对软件管理有一种泰勒式的态度，即非常等级化、非常以控制为导向、非常多地编写规范然后让程序员实现它。好吧，如果你要编写规范并让程序员
implement it, you have to divvy up your programming work in such a way that each programmer can really freely independently operate on given pieces of the software without ever really understanding the whole thing. And that comes from the management perspective. And then you get this idea that to make this clean code, you have to design these abstractions and these architectures to separate everything out so that we can change everything. And this was sort of a way forward. And if you get to that point, you sort of swallowed those ideas. Well, you can't be terse about that stuff
实现它，你必须以这样一种方式分配你的编程工作，即每个程序员都可以在不真正理解整个系统的情况下，非常自由、独立地操作软件的给定部分。这来自于管理视角。然后你得到了这个想法，即为了使代码干净，你必须设计这些抽象和架构来分离一切，以便我们可以改变一切。这是一种前进的方式。如果你到了那一点，你基本上吞下了那些想法。好吧，你不能对那些东西保持简洁
because there's so many points in there. You're, you're really, you're at a dangerous point. If you're, you're, you start to, you start wanting to not be clever, and you have systems that begin to grow very quickly because the inherent complexity of the problem also starts inheriting inherent complexity in the architecture. So your architectures start to get big. Your object hierarchies start to get big. Everything starts to sort of grow faster.
因为里面有太多的点。你，你真的，你处于一个危险的境地。如果你，你开始，你开始想要不那么聪明，而且你拥有的系统开始增长得非常快，因为问题的内在复杂性也开始继承架构中的内在复杂性。所以你的架构开始变大。你的对象层次结构开始变大。一切都开始以某种方式增长得更快。
And that means that you get these clean code books, like Bob Martin's clean code book. And these all are sort of antithetical to a terse programming style. And these are lauded as the best way to do everything. So everybody seems to get this idea that tersity is a bad thing. And they don't know why, but they have this strong institutional opinion that that's the way to go.
这意味着你得到了这些干净代码书籍，比如 Bob Martin 的《代码整洁之道》。这些在某种程度上与简洁的编程风格背道而驰。而这些被誉为做所有事情的最佳方式。所以每个人似乎都认为简洁是一件坏事。他们不知道为什么，但他们有这种强烈的体制观点，认为那是应该走的路。
Now, all of that is this big drive to push it, and that means that it's really hard to change an idea like that because Tersity is, to suggest Ters code, almost flies in the face of all of that expectation built up over decades that we're going to work with. So in order to undermine that idea, you really have to go back to a question of how you're going to approach the entire process of designing software to begin with. Going all the way back to imperative. Walk it back.
现在，所有这些都是推动它的巨大动力，这意味着改变这样的想法真的很难，因为简洁性，建议简洁代码，几乎与几十年来我们即将与之合作的所有期望背道而驰。因此，为了破坏那个想法，你真的必须回到你最初将如何处理设计软件的整个过程的问题。一直回到命令式。倒退回去。
To recap to you, what I heard, and I might miss a couple points, but you start with the rise of imperative programming back in the day called structural programming. That leads ultimately to abstraction, which leads to more abstraction, which leads to an ability to not understand the full program, which leads to modularization. And you didn't say microservices, but that's what I was kind of thinking. That's one of the next things up. And at this point, everything's become so fractured. You're not going to be terse about it. It's going to end up being verbose. And it all started with this paradigm of imperative programming
回顾一下，我听到的，我可能会漏掉几点，但你从命令式编程的兴起开始，过去称为结构化编程。这最终导致了抽象，导致了更多的抽象，导致了无法理解整个程序的能力，导致了模块化。你没有说微服务，但我当时就是这么想的。那是接下来的事情之一。在这一点上，一切都变得如此破碎。你不会对它保持简洁。它最终会变得冗长。而这一切都始于这种命令式编程的范式
that led to this kind of stuff. And I think where it gets the inflection point, if you will, is the idea of black box information hiding as object-oriented programming promotes it. So the idea that you create these objects that hide state in a way that is mechanically enforced is sort of, I think, the inflection point for this whole space.
导致了这种东西。我认为它达到拐点的地方，如果你愿意的话，是黑盒信息隐藏的想法，正如面向对象编程所推广的那样。所以，你创建这些以机械方式强制隐藏状态的对象的想法，我认为是整个空间的拐点。
And famously, Knuth didn't like this idea. It's one of his pet peeves that everybody sort of disagrees with him on. He doesn't like black box libraries. He wants editable, reusable code. So he likes reusable code that you can edit. So he sort of doesn't want that information hiding at the source level. Wait, so this is across two episodes.
著名的是，Knuth 不喜欢这个想法。这是他最讨厌的事情之一，每个人都在某种程度上不同意他。他不喜欢黑盒库。他想要可编辑、可重用的代码。所以他喜欢你可以编辑的可重用代码。所以他在某种程度上不希望在源代码层面进行那种信息隐藏。等等，所以这是跨越两集的。
The second time Knuth has come up, was he an APL fan? No, because what he liked to do is play with algorithms at the bit levels. And at the time, APL was not suitable for doing the kinds of low-level programming that he wanted. He thought, he famously, I think, said, famous, eh, it's famous to me. He said APL is a terrific problem-solving language and not the kind of programming language he wants to do because he likes to solve programming problems.
这是 Knuth 第二次出现，他是 APL 的粉丝吗？不，因为他喜欢做的是在位级别上玩弄算法。在当时，APL 不适合做他想要的低级编程。他认为，我想他曾有名言，著名，呃，对我来说很著名。他说 APL 是一种极好的问题解决语言，而不是他想做的那种编程语言，因为他喜欢解决编程问题。
He likes to play with CPUs and algorithms. And he, and APL is the thing that takes all of the algorithms he might make and makes them trivially accessible to the problem solver. And the problem solver is more interested in solving the problem than in worrying about whether he's represented this bit or that bit in exactly the precise way that's going to map onto the exact hardware machine. Whereas Knuth just goes goo-goo-ga-ga over that kind of stuff.
他喜欢玩 CPU 和算法。而他，而 APL 是那种把你可能制作的所有算法都变得对问题解决者来说微不足道地可访问的东西。而问题解决者对解决问题比担心他是否以完全映射到确切硬件机器的精确方式表示这个位或那个位更感兴趣。而 Knuth 对那种东西简直着迷。
Even inventing his own microcode more or less and instruction set to do what he wants to do so we've got to go back to square one and we have to ask ourselves are there alternatives
甚至发明了他自己的微代码，或多或少，以及指令集来做他想做的事情，所以我们必须回到原点，我们必须问自己，是否有替代方案
to managing complexity because complexity is always going to be a problem. We have to manage that, right? And so if we look at the ways that humans managed complexity in the past, sometimes there is this concept of modularization and other things, right?
来管理复杂性，因为复杂性永远是一个问题。我们必须管理它，对吧？所以如果我们看看过去人类管理复杂性的方式，有时有模块化和其他东西的概念，对吧？
But there's another concept that actually comes closer to the way we think the computers work, and that's our mathematical history. And our mathematical history is the exact opposite. Math still has the problem of complexity, having to break problems down, having to separate concerns, solve issues. But they also have the need to leverage a lot of human thought about really formal things, right?
但还有另一个概念实际上更接近我们认为计算机工作的方式，那就是我们的数学历史。我们的数学历史恰恰相反。数学仍然有复杂性的问题，必须分解问题，必须分离关注点，解决问题。但他们也需要利用大量关于非常形式化事物的思想，对吧？
So it shifts the idea from construction models, which software engineering sort of embraced the construction metaphor, to the metaphor of reasoning about concepts, or reasoning about objects, reasoning about ideas, coming up with properties and statements and things like this. And if you look at the historical development of formal thought in humans over time, when they're trying to communicate with one another, and things like this. And if you look at the historical development of formal thought in humans over time, when they're trying to communicate with one another, all of that
所以它将想法从构造模型（软件工程在某种程度上拥抱了构造隐喻）转移到了关于概念推理、关于对象推理、关于想法推理、提出属性和陈述以及诸如此类的隐喻。如果你看看人类形式化思想随时间的历史发展，当他们试图相互交流时，以及诸如此类的事情。如果你看看人类形式化思想随时间的历史发展，当他们试图相互交流时，所有这些
tends to evolve towards something that looks like math notation. And one of the hallmarks that makes math notation work is its tersity. The reason somebody uses math notation instead of just writing out the expression that could be equally formal in natural language is that it's way shorter and it's much easier to chunk into patterns for the human mind. And so if we look at like cognitive science research and we look at HCI research and things like that, and we look at how the mind engages with information ontologies, this is something we have research on now that we didn't have research on when this initial debate was happening. And we see that humans don't do well
往往会演变成看起来像数学符号的东西。使数学符号起作用的标志之一是它的简洁性。某人使用数学符号而不是仅仅写出在自然语言中同样形式化的表达式的原因是，它短得多，而且更容易为人类思维分块成模式。所以如果我们看看认知科学研究，看看 HCI 研究等等，看看思维如何与信息本体论互动，这是我们现在拥有的研究，而最初的辩论发生时我们没有这些研究。我们看到人类做得并不好
with trying to reason about abstract frameworks that can't be visualized. The ability for your typical human to reason about very complex graphs in their head and structures is really bad. That's where the common seven working items in memory kind of thing comes from. There's a general issue. And so how do humans get over that hump when they have to deal with massive complexity in the world? Well, all of our mental processing power tends to go into a type of
试图推理无法可视化的抽象框架。普通人类在脑海中推理非常复杂的图表和结构的能力真的很差。这就是常见的七个工作项在内存中那种东西的来源。这是一个普遍的问题。那么当人类必须处理世界上的巨大复杂性时，他们是如何跨越那个障碍的呢？好吧，我们所有的心理处理能力往往都进入了一种
pattern recognition space, right? A lot of what we do is pattern recognition linking to various ideas. That's where our neural network concepts came from in the computer science world. That's where case-based reasoning began to get in the early symbolic AI space. That's where we recognize the idea of chunking in memory research, where humans, in order to think about complex topics, they will chunk more complex things into units that can be stored and referenced as a single atomic entity. And it helps to build these graphs in your head that you can think of at different abstraction layers through atomic units and these chunks this sounds similar to the trick of trying to memorize some series of digits
模式识别空间，对吧？我们所做的大部分工作是链接到各种想法的模式识别。这就是计算机科学世界中神经网络概念的来源。这就是基于案例的推理在早期符号 AI 空间中开始出现的地方。这就是我们在内存研究中识别出分块概念的地方，人类为了思考复杂的主题，会将更复杂的事物分块成可以作为单个原子实体存储和引用的单元。它有助于在你的脑海中构建这些图表，你可以通过原子单元和这些块在不同的抽象层面上思考，这听起来类似于试图记忆一系列数字的技巧
into like if you split it a nine digit sequence into three three digit numbers and memorize 123 versus a couple other numbers that's an easier way to memorize instead of just nine single digits or what you can do with numbers is you can translate groups of numbers into words. Right. And then translate those words into a story. And that's leveraging more processing power than the raw memorization skills. So it's leveraging more of your brain, makes it easier to remember, and it makes it easier to recall.
比如如果你把一个九位数的序列分成三个三位数的数字，记忆 123 而不是其他几个数字，这是一种比仅仅记忆九个单个数字更容易的记忆方式，或者你可以用数字做的是你可以把数字组翻译成单词。对。然后把这些单词翻译成一个故事。这利用了比原始记忆技能更多的处理能力。所以它利用了你大脑的更多部分，使它更容易记住，也更容易回忆。
And here's something that people have forgotten about is when it's easier to memorize in your head, it's easier to immediately reason about over time. Because the connections that you're, it's sort of like caching, right? If you have to go out to disk every time you need to add two registers together, you're really slow. But if those registers are sitting right there and you can just add two registers together, that's blazingly fast. So the human mind has the same issue, right? These are levels of cache. And most people in programming right now have accepted this idea
这里有一件事人们已经忘记了，那就是当它在你的脑海中更容易记忆时，它随着时间的推移更容易立即推理。因为你正在连接的连接，它有点像缓存，对吧？如果你每次需要将两个寄存器相加时都必须去磁盘，你会非常慢。但如果那些寄存器就在那里，你可以直接将两个寄存器相加，那是非常快的。所以人类思维也有同样的问题，对吧？这些是缓存级别。现在编程中的大多数人都接受了这个想法
that there's not enough processing power in their minds, and so therefore we just have to store everything on disk. Right, and constantly reading docs and stuff like that. What they're doing is they're essentially constantly invalidating cache in their head. So they're not leveraging the caches that exist in their heads. And this is where deep learning comes in. Whereas if you have something that you've memorized in your head and you can connect that pattern to a lot of other patterns, you now have the ability to reason with that pattern across a lot of spaces way faster
他们的脑海中没有足够的处理能力，所以我们必须把所有东西都存储在磁盘上。对，不断地阅读文档之类的东西。他们所做的是，他们本质上是在不断地使脑海中的缓存失效。所以他们没有利用脑海中存在的缓存。这就是深度学习的用武之地。而如果你有你在脑海中记忆的东西，并且你可以将该模式连接到许多其他模式，你现在就有能力在许多空间中推理该模式，速度比
than if you took the equivalent concept and had to remember it by looking it up somewhere in an API reference or something else. Now, how do you apply that to programming? Well, if we look at how it's applied in math, you'll notice that there's a lot of core abstractions that mathematicians repeatedly use over and over and over across many, many different domains. Sets. Maybe if you're a homotopy type there, use types. Natural numbers, reals, all these things, these concepts all connect to each other and they form the basis of a lot of mathematical thought.
如果你采用等效概念并不得不通过在 API 参考或其他地方查找它来记住它要快得多。现在，你如何将其应用于编程？好吧，如果我们看看它是如何在数学中应用的，你会注意到数学家在许多许多不同的领域中反复使用许多核心抽象。集合。也许如果你是同伦类型，使用类型。自然数，实数，所有这些东西，这些概念都相互连接，它们构成了许多数学思想的基础。
And so if you want to reason about some other thing, you encode it into sets, symbols, numbers, you know, these other things that you now have this huge toolbox memorized in your head, ready to go. And if you look at mathematicians, they have all these theorems, they have all these practices, all these manipulations that they can do in their heads and they're ready to go. Right. And it's, and that's how they think and reason about programs. And that's how they solve the
所以如果你想推理其他事情，你把它编码成集合、符号、数字，你知道，这些其他东西，你现在在脑海中记忆了这个巨大的工具箱，准备好了。如果你看看数学家，他们有所有这些定理，他们有所有这些实践，所有这些他们可以在脑海中进行的操纵，他们准备好了。对。而且，这就是他们思考和推理程序的方式。这就是他们解决
complexity problem because they translate an idea into a representation that they have this massive toolbox of things that are easy for them to memorize that they can use but if you took a bunch of these theorems and you didn't have the formulas ready to go it's much harder to apply them that's why a lot of mathematicians use the formulas or derive the formulas before they apply the theorem they might know the theorem but then they're going to derive the formula and then they'll go apply it because that's what is easier to work with. And so if we translate this to computer science, if we want to achieve the same type of reasoning power,
复杂性问题的方式，因为他们将一个想法翻译成一个表示法，他们拥有这个巨大的工具箱，里面装满了他们容易记忆的东西，他们可以使用，但如果你拿走这些定理中的一堆，而你没有准备好公式，应用它们就困难得多，这就是为什么许多数学家在应用定理之前使用公式或推导公式，他们可能知道定理，但随后他们会推导公式，然后他们会去应用它，因为那是更容易使用的东西。所以如果我们把它翻译成计算机科学，如果我们想实现同样类型的推理能力，
expand that reasoning power in, that's the notational reasoning power that Iverson was talking about. That appeal to a symbolic language that allows us to express ideas concisely and then leverage the natural pattern matching symbolic reasoning that we have in our heads to connect those ideas with lots of other ideas because they share a common domain and they share a common symbolic language over which we can manipulate those ideas. And so we do that in computer science.
扩展那种推理能力，那就是 Iverson 谈论的符号推理能力。那种对符号语言的诉求，允许我们简洁地表达想法，然后利用我们脑海中自然的模式匹配符号推理，将这些想法与许多其他想法联系起来，因为它们共享一个共同的领域，并且它们共享一个共同的符号语言，我们可以通过它来操纵这些想法。所以我们在计算机科学中这样做。
The only way to do that is with terse languages. The more verbose your language gets, the harder it is for your mind to see the patterns, connect the patterns, and leverage them internally to think about problems. So it's like you're constantly invalidating your cache, because that verbose code is too big to naturally fit within the tightest cache regions of your mind. Whereas a terse language much more naturally connects in with all of the caches in your mind and allows you to reason more easily about those problems, especially over time, right? Because over time, those small terse expressions are reusable over and over and over again across multiple problem domains if those domains get encoded into the same base abstraction.
唯一的方法是使用简洁的语言。你的语言越冗长，你的思维就越难看到模式、连接模式并在内部利用它们来思考问题。所以这就像你不断地使你的缓存失效，因为那些冗长的代码太大，无法自然地放入你脑海中最紧密的缓存区域。而简洁的语言更自然地与你脑海中的所有缓存连接，并允许你更容易地推理这些问题，特别是在一段时间内，对吧？因为随着时间的推移，那些小的简洁表达式在多个问题领域中被反复重用，如果这些领域被编码成相同的基本抽象。
So in APL, this is the array abstraction. In Lisp, this is the links list cons model of programming. Both of them, if you can translate your ideas into those data representations, now you've got this giant suite of tools that you can apply to that data representation that you already know how to use and you can begin to see connections between ideas. And what this does is this shifts the complexity problem in a different way. What it does is it elevates,
所以在 APL 中，这是数组抽象。在 Lisp 中，这是编程的链接列表 cons 模型。两者，如果你能把你的想法翻译成那些数据表示，现在你就有了这套巨大的工具，你可以应用于你已经知道如何使用的数据表示，并且你可以开始看到想法之间的联系。这所做的是以不同的方式转移复杂性问题。它所做的是提升，
it elevates the base layer of complexity that an individual can manage. And so it doesn't invalidate all of the lessons learned in some of the software engineering stuff. But what it does is it shifts the scope. So the scope of what an individual person or mind can take on suddenly becomes much larger problem domains. Right? larger problem domains, right? And so now we don't need the overhead of the software engineering abstractions for a huge number of programs because they're too trivial to need that anymore because our human minds can handle it now. So by using Tersity to expand the range of problems
它提升了个人可以管理的复杂性的基础层。所以它并没有使软件工程中的所有教训失效。但它所做的是转移了范围。所以个人或思维可以承担的范围突然变成了更大的问题领域。对。更大的问题领域，对吧？所以现在我们不需要大量程序的软件工程抽象的开销，因为它们太琐碎了，不再需要那样了，因为我们的人类思维现在可以处理它了。所以通过使用简洁性来扩展问题的范围
that we can tackle as single people, we expand the range that we can tackle as a whole. And we tackle the complexity problem basically by removing the, making it easier for the human to tackle that complexity directly using the human mind. That's where the tools of thought come into play. So then we still have to do software engineering once we exceed that level, right? There's still, when two people have to share an idea over space and time, and it begins to exceed the capacity for the trivial, we now have to add a little bit more to manage it. But we're talking about the, like, to use my compiler as an example, most compilers have obscene amounts of abstraction in them
我们可以作为个人来解决，我们扩展了我们可以作为一个整体来解决的范围。我们基本上通过移除复杂性问题，使人类更容易直接使用人类思维来解决该复杂性。这就是思想工具发挥作用的地方。所以一旦我们超过那个水平，我们仍然必须做软件工程，对吧？仍然有，当两个人必须在空间和时间上分享一个想法时，它开始超过琐碎的能力，我们现在必须增加更多来管理它。但我们谈论的是，比如，以我的编译器为例，大多数编译器中有大量的抽象
because they need them to manage these ideas over the base abstraction layer that they're working with. But since I'm writing my compiler using APL, I don't need most of those abstractions. So all I need to do is occasionally create a function abstraction for what we would normally think of as a large module or multiple sub-modules of an idea that's linking against other concepts. And I can collapse all of that down to the idea of a function abstraction. That's a much simpler concept than
因为它们需要它们来管理这些想法，超过它们正在使用的基础抽象层。但由于我正在使用 APL 编写我的编译器，我不需要大多数那些抽象。所以我所需要做的只是偶尔为我们通常认为的大型模块或链接到其他概念的想法的多个子模块创建一个函数抽象。我可以把所有这些都折叠成函数抽象的想法。这是一个比
a visitor pattern of a particular class with a particular sub-class derived from this particular sub-AST structure that's going to then be applied using these loops and these for loops and this recursion. All of those concepts are necessary to do the similar thing for a single pass. Whereas for me, I have a single function that might contain 20 compiler passes, and each of those compiler passes needs no additional abstraction, and it's a few lines of code. And so from an informational theoretical standpoint, it's much more efficient, and therefore it's a lot easier for our minds to engage with,
具有特定子类、从该特定子 AST 结构派生的特定类的访问者模式要简单得多的概念，该模式将使用这些循环和这些 for 循环以及这种递归来应用。所有这些概念对于单次传递做类似的事情都是必要的。而对于我来说，我有一个可能包含 20 个编译器传递的单个函数，并且每个编译器传递都不需要额外的抽象，而且它是几行代码。所以从信息论的角度来看，它效率高得多，因此我们的思维更容易参与其中，
because it maps patterns that are much easier for our minds to engage with. Because it maps patterns that are much easier to reuse efficiently, quickly internally. And so that still means we have to be aware of what software engineering has given us. You know, these ideas of arranging your data in such a way that you've got independence,
因为它映射了我们的思维更容易参与的模式。因为它映射了更容易高效、快速地在内部重用的模式。所以这仍然意味着我们必须意识到软件工程给了我们什么。你知道，这些以某种方式安排你的数据，使你拥有独立性，
doing all this. But we can often do it without needing the extra overheads that are traditionally needed if we embrace Tersity now we have to develop skills around how we use Tersity effectively we have to understand what we're gaining
做所有这些。但我们通常可以在不需要传统上需要的额外开销的情况下做到这一点，如果我们拥抱简洁性，现在我们必须发展关于如何有效使用简洁性的技能，我们必须理解我们正在获得什么
from using Tersity and apply it in that fashion just like you cannot over abstract with object hires and generics and type classes or whatever in your oop language if you do that you end up with spaghetti code just like anybody else and it's horrible code you have to learn how to use your tools effectively and tersity is another one of those tools you need to learn to use effectively but it allows you to obviate the need for a whole
通过使用简洁性并以这种方式应用它，就像你不能在你的 OOP 语言中过度抽象对象层次结构和泛型和类型类或任何东西一样，如果你那样做，你最终会得到意大利面条式代码，就像其他人一样，它是可怕的代码，你必须学习如何有效地使用你的工具，而简洁性是你需要学习有效使用的工具之一，但它允许你通过仅仅利用一个更简单的工具来消除对一大堆其他工具的需求，如果你学习如何使用它，我的意思是，鞠个躬，那真是，我一直坐在这里，在听你说话时陷入沉思，干杯，干杯，那太棒了，我们坐的桌子在八分钟后有预订，所以我们会在那之前结束并让这架飞机着陆，但每隔一段时间，你就会进行一次谈话，它会点亮你的大脑，因为你说的几乎所有事情都让我想到了，我将不得不迭代我脑海中的这个引语，但有类似 ADSP 的东西，我们之前讨论过 C++ 中的算法有多么重要。很多人会问，我为什么要学习这些算法？一个 for 循环不就够了吗？我们在本播客中一直主张，算法能提升你的词汇量。这里有一个类比，介于你所说的一切之间。而在我的脑后
lot of other tools by just leveraging one simpler tool if you learn how to use it i mean take a bow that was i've i've been sitting here like deep in thought while listening to you cheers cheers that was amazing we're at a table that has a reservation in eight minutes so we'll wrap this up and land this plane before them but that every once in a while, you have a conversation where it lights up your brain because almost everything you were saying there made me think about, I'll have to iterate on this quote that I have in my head, but there's something like on ADSP, we've talked about before how algorithms in C++ are so important. There's a lot of people that say, why do I have to go learn these algorithms? A for loop is good enough. And we've advocated on this podcast that algorithms elevate your vocabulary. And there's an analogy here between everything you were saying. And in the back of
我心想，这让我想到了 C++ 中的算法对你的词汇量所做的事情，简洁性对你理解和解决问题的能力所做的事情。所以就像算法的词汇表，比如 rotate、reverse、reduce 和 scan，那个词汇表让你更容易与同事交流。比如如果我必须说一个带有 if 检查的 for 循环，不，它是 find if，它是归约。那个词汇表在口头交流甚至在代码中与同事交流时为你所做的同样的事情，简洁性在架构和解决问题以及你查看代码屏幕并看到整个解决方案的能力方面为你所做的事情。即使有很多事情正在发生，你也可以在单个屏幕或单个函数中看到它，而在命令式范式中，
my head, I'm like, it's making me think that what algorithms in C++ do for your vocabulary, tersity does for your ability to comprehend and solve problems. So like the same way that a vocabulary of algorithms like rotate and reverse and reduce and scan, that vocabulary makes it easier for you to communicate with your coworkers. Like if I have to say a for loop that has an if thing that checks, no, it's a find if, it's a reduction. The same thing that that vocabulary does for you when communicating verbally and even in code with your coworkers, the same thing Tersity does for you when it comes to architecture and solving problems and your ability to look at a screen of code and see the whole solution. Even if there's a lot of stuff going on, you can see it on a single screen or in a single function, whereas in an imperative paradigm,
你需要所有这些抽象。你可能甚至不需要，在命令式风格中，不需要抽象，但这只是习惯上完成它的方式。你正在使用类之类的东西。那里有一些类比，它真的让我想到了我们前几天关于库是否有必要的两小时讨论。我并没有完全被说服，或者根本没有被说服，我们不需要它们。
you're going to need all this abstraction. You might not even, in the imperative style, need the abstraction, but that's just the way that idiomatically it's done. You're using classes and stuff. There's some analogy there that it's really making me think that we had a two-hour discussion the other day about whether libraries are necessary. And I wasn't fully convinced or at all convinced that we don't need them.
你需要所有这些抽象。在命令式风格中，你甚至可能根本不需要这种抽象，但这只是惯用做法而已。你正在使用类之类的东西。这其中有一些类比，让我不禁想起前几天我们关于是否需要库进行了两个小时的讨论。我并没有完全被说服，或者说根本不相信我们不需要它们。
But everything you said over the last 15 minutes or so, I can see how you get to a less of a need for libraries. If algorithms are your vocabulary, notation is the analog of that for thought or something like that. Well, the vocabulary and the tersity empower each other. So if you have a well-selected vocabulary that is expressive and general, then if it's an economical vocabulary, then a terse notation for using those vocabulary terms allows you to chain them together in patterns that allow you to use them more effectively, more easily, and scales their applicability farther.
但你在过去15分钟左右所说的一切，我能看出你是如何得出对库的需求减少这一结论的。如果算法是你的词汇，那么符号就是思想的类比，或者类似的东西。嗯，词汇和简洁性是相辅相成的。因此，如果你拥有一个表达力强且通用的精选词汇表，那么如果它是一个经济的词汇表，那么使用这些词汇的简洁符号就能让你以各种模式将它们串联起来，从而使你能够更有效、更轻松地使用它们，并进一步扩展它们的适用性。
Right, right, right. And you used the word elevate at one point, and I was literally thinking that. You're elevating not just your ability to think in your head, but your ability to iterate and solve. Because it's one of my biggest complaints when swapping between APL and C++ is I can try out. I literally have a talk called Algorithms as a Tool of Thought where I show 10 or 11 different. Great talk, by the way. Great talk.
对，对，对。你曾用过“提升”这个词，我当时就在想这个。你不仅是在提升你在脑中思考的能力，还在提升你迭代和解决问题的能力。因为在APL和C++之间切换时，我最大的抱怨之一就是我能尝试……我确实有一个名为《算法作为思维工具》的演讲，我在其中展示了10或11种不同的……顺便说一句，那是个很棒的演讲。非常棒的演讲。
You provided solution number nine or something. And it's like 10 different solutions in 30 minutes in a slide deck. All of them, I think the most was six characters, and most of them are three or four or five. In C++, you can't give, I mean, you probably could, but you're burning through those solutions because every single one of those primitives in APL is hopefully the equivalent of an algorithm in C++,
你提供了第九种左右的解决方案。在幻灯片里，30分钟内展示了10种不同的解决方案。我想其中最长的也就6个字符，大多数是3、4或5个字符。在C++中，你无法给出……我是说，你可能可以，但你是在消耗那些解决方案，因为APL中的每一个原语，希望都等同于C++中的一个算法，
but not all of them, so you're going to end up spelling out some boilerplate, and the making of that talk in APL, it's an order of magnitude, if not less, than the equivalent preparation for C++ code, because coding the equivalents, they don't just... The namespaces on a single operation in the C++ code
但并非所有原语都是如此，所以你最终会写出一些样板代码。在APL中制作那个演讲，其准备工作量比C++代码的等效准备工作量少了一个数量级，甚至更多，因为编写等效代码时，它们不仅仅是……C++代码中单个操作的命名空间
already exceeds the length of the solution in APL. And just the difficulty of presenting that kind of code to an audience is hugely magnified. Yeah. And there's so much more. Just the namespaces, like when it comes to C++, I'm definitely an algorithm expert. And there's like four different now, you need to know the iterator algorithms from C++ 98, plus the ones that were added in 14, 17. Then in 20, you get the ranges overloads of them. Then we get views, which technically are not algorithms, but you would call them. Anyway, so there's like four or five different things.
就已经超过了APL中解决方案的长度。向观众展示那种代码的难度被极大地放大了。是的。而且还有更多。仅仅是命名空间，就C++而言，我绝对是算法专家。现在有四种不同的……你需要了解C++ 98的迭代器算法，加上14、17年添加的那些。然后在20标准中，你得到了它们的范围重载。然后我们有了视图，虽然技术上它们不是算法，但你会调用它们。总之，大约有四五种不同的东西。
And then there's the parallel algorithms that I didn't even mention. It is impossible for a beginner to keep that stuff in their head. I've been doing this since like 2014. Whereas in APL, it was designed well from the get-go this is a question of economy right is tersity empowers economical expression and if you have economical expression it allows you to be simpler longer for more complexity right you can stay simple for more complex problems if you haven't the ability to be economical with your vocabulary, with your domain, with your expression, your notation, everything. Whereas as things become more difficult,
还有我甚至没提到的并行算法。初学者根本不可能把这些东西记在脑子里。我从2014年左右就开始做这个了。而在APL中，它从一开始就设计得很好。这是一个经济性问题，对吧？简洁性赋予了经济表达能力，如果你有经济的表达能力，它就能让你在更长的时间内保持简单，以应对更多的复杂性。对吧？如果你有能力在词汇、领域、表达、符号等方面做到经济，你就能在处理更复杂的问题时保持简单。然而，随着事情变得越来越困难，
you need more to get a handle on it. And as you get more, you need more. And C++ is the poster child of needing more to do more. And they make the right choice for what they need to do because of the constraints they're working under, but it leads to a proliferation of vocabulary and syntax and names and everything, whereas that's all fundamentally unnecessary, even if it's practically required for them as a design problem
你需要更多的东西来掌控它。当你得到更多时，你需要更多。C++是“需要更多来做更多”的典型代表。他们因为所处的约束条件而为自己需要做的事情做出了正确的选择，但这导致了词汇、语法、名称等各方面的激增，而从根本上说，即使这对他们来说是一个设计问题上的实际需求，这些都是不必要的，
at the space that they're at right now. Is it possible for a non-symbolic language to gain the power of tersity? It is possible, but it requires an intentional rejection of the tools that the languages provide you, which is very difficult because you can't use all those syntactic extras. You have to strip it down and simplify your expressions so that you can try to take advantage of at least a little bit of tersity. You can get a lot of advantages without going all the way to the symbols, but there isn't a really strong inflection point that you hit really quickly if you don't leverage symbols to the full effect
在他们目前所处的空间里。非符号语言有可能获得简洁的力量吗？有可能，但这需要有意拒绝语言提供给你的工具，这非常困难，因为你不能使用所有那些语法上的额外内容。你必须剥离它并简化你的表达式，这样你才能尝试利用至少一点点简洁性。你可以在不完全使用符号的情况下获得很多优势，但如果你不充分利用符号，你就不会很快达到一个非常强的拐点，
because there's a big difference between a page of code, a line of code, and a couple of pages of code. And every time you double or triple your size, you are cutting out a massive amount of work that you can do, right? So in my compiler, four lines of code is a huge difference between that and, say, four lines of code is a huge difference between that and like, say, 20 lines of code. So you can write some really nice, small, clean C++ code, but you're only going partway there and you're still going to hit really hard barriers until
因为一页代码、一行代码和几页代码之间有很大的区别。每当你将规模增加一倍或三倍时，你就在削减你可以完成的大量工作，对吧？所以在我的编译器中，四行代码和……四行代码与比如20行代码之间有巨大的差异。所以你可以写出一些非常漂亮、简短、干净的C++代码，但你只是走了一部分路，你仍然会遇到非常硬的障碍，直到
you sort of swallow the entire concept, you know? And some people just are not going to want to swallow that concept, but that's where the biggest power lies. And that's why math notation inevitably needs its symbols. You can't really do the math without the symbols. People would just invent more symbols at some point. Because once you get to a certain point of doing real work, the symbols are required to achieve the control over complexity that you want. Well, this has been amazing. I'm going to have fun editing this
你某种程度上接受了整个概念，你知道吗？有些人就是不想接受那个概念，但那正是最大力量所在的地方。这就是为什么数学符号不可避免地需要它的符号。没有符号，你真的无法进行数学运算。人们在某个时候会发明更多的符号。因为一旦你达到进行实际工作的某个点，就需要符号来实现你想要的对复杂性的控制。嗯，这太棒了。我会很享受编辑这一期的过程，
because I'm going to be deep in thought again while I edit this. Thanks for letting me rant. This was the goal and it was achieved. Thank you so much. We'll do this again sometime. Absolutely. Be sure to check these show notes
因为我在编辑时会再次陷入深思。感谢你让我发泄。这就是目标，而且已经实现了。非常感谢。我们以后还会再做一次。当然。一定要查看这些节目笔记，
either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSPthepodcast.com上，都可以找到我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“带有信息点缀的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。